THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET
TRANSPARENCY AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT DOES.
>> ALEX MARQUARDT, THANKS SO
MUCH.
>>> LET'S BRING IN BOB WOODWARD.
IT WAS HIS REPORTING ABOUT
GENERAL MILLEY IN "PERIL" THAT
PROMPTED KEY PORTIONS OF TODAY'S
QUESTIONING.
THE BOOK CO-AUTHORED WITH ROBERT
COSTA.
BOB, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GENERAL MILLEY WAS ASKED TODAY
ABOUT THE CALL THAT YOU BROKE IN
YOUR BOOK.
HIS CALL WITH THE CHINESE
COUNTERPART JANUARY 8th, TWO
DAYS AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
THE GENERAL DESCRIBED THE CALL
AS ROUTINE, EVEN THOUGH HE HAD
TO REASSURE CHINA THE U.S. WAS
STABLE AND TRUMP WASN'T SECRETLY
PLANNING A STRIKE AGAINST THEM.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> AND I TOLD HIM THAT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO ATTACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NO INTENT TO
ATTACK.
AND I TOLD HIM THAT REPEATEDLY.
AND I TOLD HIM IF THERE WAS
GOING TO BE AN ATTACK, THERE
WILL BE PLENTY OF COMMUNICATIONS
GOING BACK AND FORTH.
YOUR INTEL SYSTEM IS GOING TO
PICK IT UP.
I SAID I'LL PROBABLY CALL YOU.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ATTACK YOU.
JUST SETTLE DOWN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> YOU WRITE IN YOUR BOOK IT
TOOK AN HOUR AND A HALF FOR
MILLEY TO CONVEY THAT THOS
CHINESE COUNTERPART AND WHEN
MILLEY HUNG UP YOU WRITE, HE WAS
CONVINCED THE SITUATION WAS
GRAVE.
LEE REMAINED UNUSUALLY RATTLED
PUTTING THE TWO NATIONS ON THE
KNIFE EDGE OF DISASTER.
FROM YOUR REPORTING, HOW CLOSE
WAS THE U.S. TO SOME MILITARY --
>> WELL, MILLEY'S WHOLE POINT IN
THIS IS THAT MISCOMMUNICATION IS
THE SEED OF WAR.
AND AS WE KNOW NOW, THE
RELATIONS WITH CHINA, ALL OF
THESE EXERCISES GOING ON AROUND
TAIWAN AND THE SOUTH CHINA SEA,
IT IS -- IT COULD NOT BE MORE OF
A DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT.
AS WE KNOW, CHINA IS ON THE
MARCH.
THEY ARE REASSERTING THEMSELVES
IN MANY WAYS.
AND IF YOU EXAMINE THESE, AND
I'VE DONE THIS FOR ABOUT 50
YEARS.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND I'VE RARELY SEEN A CASE
WHERE THE REPORTING IS
SUBSTANTIATED BY A PARTICIPANT
UNDER OATH.
HE DID SAY THAT HE IS NOT
QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> WHICH IS NOT TO SAY HE
DOESN'T HAVE AN OPINION.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S NOT DENIAL OF WHAT IS IN
THE TRANSCRIPT, WHICH IS VERY
FORC
FORCEFUL.
I SUSPECT LOTS OF PEOPLE OVER
THE YEARS HAVE SAID SOMEBODY'S
CRAZY, AND THEY, TOO, WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THEY ARE NOT
QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THAT IS MEDICALLY OR
PSYCHOLOGICALLY TRUE.
>> YEAH, I WANT TO GET TO THAT
IN ONE SECOND.
AS A QUICK BUTTON ON THIS.
DO YOU THINK IF GENERAL MILLEY,
BASED ON YOUR REPORTING, HAD NOT
MADE THAT CALL, HAD NOT MADE
THAT EFFORT TO CONVINCE GENERAL
LI, HIS COUNTERPART, GENERAL LI,
HIS COUNTERPART, NOT TO
OVERREACT, DO YOU THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT SOMETHING MIGHT
HAVE HAPPENED?
>> MILLEY FELT THAT'S THE CASE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THIS AND YOU
GO TO THE ENVIRONMENT, THE FIRST
CALL WAS OCTOBER 30th, FOUR DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THE MOST CONTENTIOUS ELECTION IN
MODERN HISTORY.
AND TRUMP WAS OUT THERE ACCUSING
CHINA.
IT'S THE CHINA VIRUS.
HE WAS SAYING THINGS ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU GET,
WHICH MILLEY ACKNOWLEDGED TODAY,
VERY SENSITIVE INTELLIGENCE THAT
THE CHINESE THINK WE'RE GOING TO
ATTACK THEM.
THAT IS THE DISASTER ENVIRONMENT
FOR SOMEBODY IN THE MILITARY
BECAUSE, AS MILLEY TOLD HIS
SENIOR STAFF, YOU MIGHT WIND UP
GETTING A PEARL HARBOR.
SOMEONE WILL MAKE THE FIRST
MOVE.
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED IF HE HADN'T DONE
THIS, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT --
THESE ARE REASONABLE
PRECAUTIONS.
WE FOUND NO EVIDENCE, AND BOB
COSTA AND I HAD MONTHS TO LOOK
AT THIS, THAT MILLEY HAD DONE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN WHAT HE FELT
IN A CRISIS MOMENT WAS, I'M
GOING TO DO THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
TO PROTECT THE UNITED STATES.
>> PROTECT THE UNITED STATES AND
MAKE SURE NO LIVES WERE SHED
UNNECESSARILY.
GENERAL MILLEY, LET'S TALK ABOUT
HIS CONVERSATION WITH HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI WHO WAS
WORRIED THAT TRUMP WOULD GO
ROGUE AND LAUNCH NUCLEAR
STRIKES.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> SHE WAS CONCERNED AND MADE
VERY -- OR MADE VARIOUS PERSONAL
REFERENCES, CHARACTERIZING THE
PRESIDENT.
I EXPLAINED TO HER THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THE SOLE NUCLEAR
LAUNCH AUTHORITY, AND HE DOESN'T
LAUNCH THEM ALONE.
AND THAT I AM NOT QUALIFIED TO
DETERMINE THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> NOW THAT DOES NOT CONTRADICT
YOUR REPORT CHICING WHICH IS TH
PELOSI SAYS -- YOU HAVE A
TRANSCRIPT OF THIS CONVERSATION.
PELOSI SAYS, YOU KNOW HE'S
CRAZY.
HE'S BEEN CRAZY FOR A LONG TIME
AND MILLEY SAYS, MADAM SPEAKER,
I AGREE WITH YOU ON EVERYTHING.
>> AND THEN HE LATER SAYS, I
AGREE WITH YOU 100%.
I MEAN, THERE'S NO AMBIGUITY
THERE.
LOOK, THE BOOK SHOWS THAT HE
RESPONDED MOST SIGNIFICANTLY,
AND I THOUGHT THIS IS SOMETHING
HE WOULD NOT TOUCH IN AN
UNCLASSIFIED PUBLIC BRIEFING,
THAT HE WAS SO WORRIED THAT HE
CALLED IN THE OFFICERS FROM THE
NATIONAL MILITARY COMMAND
CENTER.
THIS IS THE PENTAGON WAR ROOM.
>> YEAH.
>> AND SAID, MAKE SURE -- MAKE
SURE I AM IN THE LOOP AS
PROCEDURES CALLED.
THE LAST TIME WE SAW THAT HAPPEN
WAS 1974 WHEN SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE SCHLESINGER DID THE SAME
THING BECAUSE HE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT NIXON AND HIS MENTAL
STATE.
SO THIS WAS A MOMENT OF MAXIMUM
PERIL.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY UNDER
PRESSURE.
WE SIT -- COSTA AND I
PONTIFICATED ON THIS A LITTLE.
WELL, WHAT SHOULD HE DO?
YOU LEARNED FROM VERY SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE THAT THE CHINESE
THINK WE'RE GOING TO -- THIS IS
A CRISIS MOMENT.
YOU HAVE A PRACTICAL PROBLEM TO
TALK GENERAL LI DOWN.
AND HE SAID SOME THINGS THAT HE
EXPLAINED TODAY.
WE EXPLAIN IN OUR BOOK.
THIS IS NOT TO TIP THE CHINESE
OFF.
THIS IS TO MAKE SURE IN THEIR
FIVE-YEAR RELATIONSHIP THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TALK TO EACH
OTHER IF THERE ARE TENSIONS.
YOU WILL SEE A BUILD-UP.
AND I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE AND
BOB COSTA SAID IT BEFORE.
WHEN THIS SIS ALL WASHED OUT,
THOSE WHO ARE SAYING THAT
GENERAL MILLEY ACTUALLY WAS
TREASONOUS IN WHAT HE DID, I
THINK ARE GOING TO OWE THE
GENERAL AN APOLOGY.
>> SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT -- OF THE STEPS HE TOOK TO
TRY TO PREVENT ANY SORT OF
NUCLEAR STRIKE BECAUSE AT ONE
POINT YOU WRITE THAT MILLEY --
GENERAL MILLEY TELLS SPEAKER
PELOSI THERE'S NOT A SNOWBALL'S
CHANCE IN HELL THIS PRESIDENT OR
ANY PRESIDENT CAN LAUNCH WEAPONS
ILLEGALLY, IMMORALLY WITHOUT
PROPER SOINGS.
BUT I HAVE TO ASK, BASED ON THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
CHANGE THIS --
>> YES.
>> -- DID MILLEY TAKE ANY STEPS
THAT WOULD HAVE LED HIM TO BE
ABLE TO STOP TRUMP IF HE WAS
ABOUT TO LAUNCH OR JUST TO BRING
HIM IN THE LOOP?
>> YEAH, TO BRING HIM IN THE
LOOP SO HE WOULD BE AT THE TABLE
AND PRESUMABLY RAISE HIS HAND
AND SAY, WAIT A MINUTE, IS THIS
NECESSARY?
IS THIS ONE OF THESE OCCASIONS
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS?
>> PRESIDENTS HAVE THE POWER
PRETTY MUCH UNILATERALLY TO
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR STRIKE.
>> AND MILLEY DID NOT TAKE AWAY
ANY OF TRUMP'S POWER.
HE JUST SAID, YOU KNOW, THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS IS
NOT IN THE CHAIN OF COMMAND.
HE IS ADJACENT TO THE COMMAND TO
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND, AND WHAT
HE DID -- LET'S ENFORCE THE
PROCEDURES THAT DO EXIST AND
MAKE SURE IT IS CAUTION AND IT
IS CAUTION.
JAMES SCHLESINGER, THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY IN 1974, GOD, THAT'S
ALMOST 50 YEARS AGO, EXERCISED
THE SAME PRECAUTION.
WHY?
BECAUSE TRUMP ACTUALLY SET THE
STAGE FOR ALL OF THIS WITH HIS
ACTIONS AND HIS DENUNCIATIONS
AND MILLEY AND OTHERS
EXPERIENCED THIS SCREAMING IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
WE HAVE THE SCENES IN THE BOOK.
>> CRAZY.
IT'S REALLY WELL RENDERED AND
REALLY IMPORTANT.
FOR ANYBODY WATCHING RIGHT NOW,
ESPECIALLY LAWMAKERS, WE MIGHT
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THE IDEA OF
WHETHER THE UNITED STATES SHOULD
HAVE JUST ONE PERSON, WHATEVER
PARTY, BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT TO UNILATERALLY
LAUNCH A NUCLEAR STRIKE,
CHANGING PERHAPS EVEN ENDING THE
WORLD.
SOMETHING FOR US TO THINK ABOUT.
THE FOUNDERS WEREN'T HIP ON THE
NUCLEAR WEAPON THING WHEN THEY
CREATED OUR BALANCE OF POWER.
>> THEY DID NOT.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT CLEAR.
AND LOTS OF EXPERTS AND THEY
OUGHT TO LOOK AT IT AND THEY
OUGHT TO SETTLE IT AND PEOPLE
OUGHT TO KNOW THERE MAY BE NO NO
MORE IMPORTANT MATTER THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE AND EXECUTIVES
SHOULD TAKE UP.
>> VERY IMPORTANT LESS